David Arquette what's going on VIN how
are you good buddy how you doing how are
you wonderful thank you David Arquette
welcome to show me in once muffin what
is your schedule been like today not too
bad this is my first stop isn't it nice
when the first stop is after 10 a.m. yes
yeah nothing worse than I mean I got to
do it on the road to morning press and
like you see that you publish to send to
the first one 6:45 you like off [ __ ]
on it's the worst what's that did you
publish it do a lot for you or their
times but you don't have one I put my
publicist on and off depending on if you
got promotion something yeah
or then if some scandal breaks did you
ever enlist with you they have PR people
who do damage control
like with Weinstein's got like
apparently an amazing one now that he
that is obviously there's nothing they
can do
right yeah they're leaving by this have
you had to hire anybody or ever like no
not really
I sorted I do my own damage there's no
control I don't know I kind of make my
own trouble but you know I've dealt with
my stuff now now I'm like I go to sleep
early you know I don't mind wake your
publicist is getting pissed because
she's like it used to be like every
three months there'd be something I call
you for a milky out of some more Adele
but there's nothing to clean up no pity
boy did you ever have those times where
you feel like oh no I [ __ ] out and
it's gonna it's not gonna stop this bad
vibe is not gonna stop this this
negative stuff coming towards me is
going to continue and just roll me over
yeah I mean that's yeah I've been to
rehab twice and and just sort of that
whole thing so you know you dig your own
grave really you know I mean it's
usually your actions that are leading to
all this crap anyway so how do people
receive you and you came out because
normally in Hollywood especially if you
just you screw up and you kind of make
good people are pretty forgiving
especially about like drug and alcohol
stuff yeah I mean depending
it depends kind of have to own it and
you have to sort of you know figure it
out for yourself I'm not like the sober
guy cuz I'm not sober now but I'm I've
got everything sort of I've dealt with
what I had to like the underlying issues
that led me to sort of escapism okay and
then what do you have to like kind of
rebuild the reputation so you can prove
to people like no he's a responsible
dude like we can count on him because
that's what it is today but you know a
lot of the time you burned a lot of
bridges along the way and it's kind of
like you miss opportunities and you end
up with a podcast yeah so so have you do
you feel like you burnt yeah I feel like
your your your generally these days not
like you know the kind of wild dude that
you were at one point no but it just
looks sort of like at the peak times of
your career it's when you I said really
be like vigilant and be selective and do
that make the right move so that you can
you know the right kind of movies that
you want to do does that haunt you at
all like when you go like ah if I just
made like if I'd done something
different after scream or this one or
that one then I'd be over here yeah or
do you not think about it no I think
about it sometimes you know like
something like Lalla where did you're
like oh well have you turned any down
never like that because there are people
that turn them down or they're too
difficult and they get someone else
there was a couple stories of people on
lala land that they originally wanted
for it that didn't do it yeah are there
any that you look at like [ __ ] I
shouldn't turn that down yeah I was
supposed to go up for Arrested
Development and they were really
interested in meeting me I was like I'm
too young to be a dad yeah once in a
while I guess you can't tell though like
if you had done it would it have been
sometimes you wonder like Harvey Keitel
was shooting Apocalypse Now yeah and I
think would it have been Apocalypse Now
with Harvey Keitel do that much good for
Jason Bateman right I didn't completely
rebuild his career anything happy for
but um yeah you never know I worked with
Harvey Keitel once
trip it was called the gray zone and he
played a Nazi we played a bunch of
Jewish prisoners but we were also sort
of like these soldiers that like fooled
the Jews into going into the gas chamber
so we were like bad Jews but he didn't
talk to us for like two months of
filming we're the same hotel we're at
the same restaurants they're like you
can't talk to him you can't look at him
it's not a method acting either that or
he's just an [ __ ] and he's blaming it
after you that we are at dinner together
it was great oh it's gotta suck if
you're like yeah talking like a guy like
Harvey that you want to talk to and you
just can't yeah yeah you're like if I
was if I was in that scenario and like
had a great time with him the last night
I'd be like oh [ __ ] I wish I'd been a
Nazi in this movie did he did he talk in
a German accent nein or did he kind of
just do it like this slight German
accent or a pretty strong German accent
yeah it was intense it was a sick movie
it's crazy and how is your sister doing
here's now she's kind of in the in the
story of Harvey Weinstein yeah and as a
brother did you know that before or what
was or you a little bit yeah I kind of
knew you know I knew like you know just
like that kind of vibe but I'm really
proud of my sister for coming out and
and you know all the women that sort of
stood up and and it's sad it's
unfortunate it happens more than people
think it's a bigger this kind of a tip
of the iceberg I mean Trump to be honest
with you was one of those kind of guys
that had a similar kind of reputation
and a bunch of people do so I don't know
it's so did it hurt her career at all to
ever have refused him or no I don't know
I mean if you'd have to ask her but I
think she kind of felt that way Waller
do you do you know what like like do you
know what hurts your career or do you
just notice at some point you're like a
[ __ ]
I pissed somebody off somewhere because
right or do you like do you ever know
exactly like that was what it was or
just okay I obviously pissed somebody
off at some point sometimes yeah I mean
there's a look and you could trace some
of it back and then you don't know and
like you've worked with some people then
you never work with them again or don't
hear from them whatever
I don't need sometimes you could trace
it back yeah with Harvey Weinstein it
was just like there was a vibe about him
that people kind of knew or did people
really know like this dude is a [ __ ]
creep I don't know like all this stuff
you kind of hear stuff throughout the
like the little story so I don't know
I'm glad he's getting help and I don't
want to sort of pile on well how do you
how do you think people always go hey
how come no one speaks up right but
isn't like that nobody gets into a room
whenever but no one has like a real
discussion in front of 50 people it's
just like little things that you hear
here and there then you forget about it
and someone else says yeah yeah whatever
if he's a lot of crazy [ __ ] that happens
in Hollywood in general are you afraid
of him though like it could he hurt you
are you afraid that he could still hurt
you why why because I seen him you know
I had this Club at the time called
Beacher's Madhouse they were doing the
premiere of Black Swan there and he was
he's like I just ran into him I was
[ __ ] wasted at the time I was like
one of my bad moments of life so he was
like he was acting like he didn't know
me and I was like you know I did scream
for you know dimension which made them a
ton of [ __ ] money I was like so I was
like hey Harvey it's David Arquette he's
like hey David I just I don't know I
think it was some of the stories I'd
heard in the past and so I just kind of
got all up in his face and then my
partner was like David doing crazy yeah
it was just it wasn't a pretty seed so
but he can't leave me out of there
and then answer your phone to the pool
so you're a confrontation you wanted
actually done anything though yeah well
he's like you know acting like you
didn't know who the [ __ ] I was in front
of your partner now when you say partner
yeah business but oh okay so not my gay
know married right
I am remarried yes right but my partner
is there a certain amount of intolerant
like cuz actresses don't seem so
sensitive that like if one guy hits on
and they fall apart like is there a
certain amount of it like alright we
expect the producer wants to a while is
gonna ask you out but then once it goes
past that point of just asking it
becomes alright this is [ __ ] up yeah I
think this is gonna be I think there's a
lot of like you know there's the whole
woke thing like people are waking up to
a lot of stuff going on in general with
health with you know behaviors with sort
of what's going on in the world so I
think that's that's what's happening I
think you know and it takes a lot of
people like working on themselves yeah
when you get to a certain age if you
haven't like really addressed these
serious issues in your life they're
gonna keep coming back and tossing
trouble so I think it's just a matter of
like you know I'm glad people are
talking about it I'm glad it's getting
out there I'm glad you know there's a
dialogue happening cuz it is there's a
lot of gray area and there's a lot of
like workplace weirdness and so the
Hollywood scene like not the same scene
anymore where a David Arquette type
could get drunk threaten an executive
and fall in the pool
I don't think this irrational drunk can
be here like sometimes you like a guy
will say something you'd like you
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
congratulations Harvey the movies
incredible it's his movie your it's your
club like there's supposed to be some
kind of professional like something blue
yeah Beacher's Madhouse it was a comedy
yeah staying with Jeff Beecher I mean
Vegas I bombed so me and Bobby Kelly did
it I [ __ ] ate my dick at that
Beacher's Madhouse
oh but it's pretty tough room like it's
not set up for comedy no there's a sword
swallower and then me ironically and
then and then Bob and an iced tea was in
the front and I remember I was just
thank you for that thing and then he
moved to Vegas was that was that new
that started yeah he started in New York
it was I don't know but that thing in
Vegas it was like it's like we used to
do the boxcar yeah it's like he would
promote the [ __ ] out of that though and
always people see you with him before
after that yeah before and then I moved
on and started a different club called
Bootsy bellows in Los Angeles
I'm always pootie bellows Bootsy bellows
is night club again but we have puppets
there it's pretty crazy we have big rap
acts a lot of the time and stuff like
that oh yes you're still open yeah I was
about to open in Dallas we have one in
Aspen remember the bigger acts that
you've had in just sort of all the top
rappers yeah I mean Drake's been there
and all right so when you open a club
like all of a sudden it changes like
okay you're an actor you now all of a
sudden you're a club owner with a liquor
license like is this whole bunch of like
insurances and pressures like how do you
focus on acting when you got to worry
about all this other [ __ ]
well I've great partners with the h.wood
group these guys Brian and John and they
sort of they handle a lot of that stuff
more like the you know help promote it
the name partner have fun you know so
when you're getting like
when you're in your in your darker
periods where you're getting like [ __ ]
up [ __ ] up but you're owning clubs
like are your partner's like David this
isn't your playground you got to calm
down or is that part of the appeal like
you could come to our club and get
[ __ ] up over here it wasn't a little
point but there's the tipping point that
is just way too crazy and you know you
do something that you end up having a
call and apologize to people yeah it's a
hard balancing act but you know if you
could figure it out if you do it right
and you know you responsible about
everything it's all about Barron woods
ultimately anyway for me do you find it
is it hard to keep it balanced is hard
to be balanced especially when you're
known and you can kind of do whatever
you want within reason and you can get
away with a lot it's hard to stay
balanced I think when they get older I
think I don't know I feel like getting
older it's been like pretty yeah making
it a lot more manageable you know what I
mean like don't you feel like you've
addressed a lot of your issues and he's
been laughing at my midlife crisis to 49
but it's not I don't want to go out and
do crazy things I've done a lot of them
yeah it's like now you just want to come
out
Jim's midlife crisis is like he turned
49 right and all of a sudden like he's
looking at 50 and instead of doing like
oh I never got that Corvette oh you know
I stopped drinking when I was 18 I got
start getting [ __ ] up I guess they're
doing coke he's like you know I really
want a girlfriend you know I always said
I didn't want to get married but you
know I don't know kids could be kind of
fun like it's completely the opposite of
the way it's amazing life when you kids
like totally my second round of kids I
have a thirty year old daughter now I
have two young ones boys and it's it's
the best one you know like you going to
rehab
obviously you cross that fine line from
social use to addiction yeah how do you
come back and and be a social drinker
party because both of us are in recovery
right is it hard to answer this question
for a man wearing that hat
oh sure by the moment ago no because I
always sure all the years sober I have
then you always hear people that go go
back out or start drinking again okay
yeah again that the everyone says I
can't do it successfully do you know
what I'm saying yeah yeah no I mean it's
it's hard and you know I've had a few
nights where I drank too much you know
you don't do anything else you try to
limit it to two drinks you know three
and once you get past three it's just
not not pretty
yeah once you see a mogul and you want
to strangle them cool thing and then
I've like slipped and like I'm
underwater I'm like oh [ __ ] I just fell
under water are you embarrassed the next
day so embarrassed
yeah I've had my moments were like bro
you can't you know but you know what
kick some up and cover no huge musical
act in the nuts musical act in the nuts
yeah that's it was totally my fault
you being you plan on you hope you just
right well yeah with a rock or a rap
what instrument is a person play that
you can what she cut around the suitors
singer singers okay so how many years
ago roughly ten years yeah it wasn't
okay who's the supergroup it was the
[ __ ] you know who those are really
good-looking supergroup the one that
does
Delvin see chris kirkpatrick went down
who'd you kick in the balls but yeah
right bring it up this is the kind of
stuff right but i don't understand what
my mind does right you know what i mean
why would i bring that up but who else
who else who'd you kicking the ball but
you want to look for it if it's out
there if it's out there we'll find it I
just tapped it know why he was standing
in front of me I was behind it why do
you why did you do that why did I do a
thing a bottle cap okay joking around as
a chaser
I'm gonna [ __ ] you yeah I flicked him in
the nuts with my shoe did he yeah Justin
Bieber ask David Arquette to leave his
20 former Justin Bieber was that you
gotta get out of here first birthday
party at a club we're representing and I
kicked him in the balls that was shortly
before by second yeah that's a great we
have story what did you do I didn't show
up for it I kicked Justin Bieber in the
dick is here from this guy that's your
story I wanted this was at your club or
one of your part of book club omnia in
las vegas and the heart a tom no the VIP
room there so you're like you're like we
got Justin Bieber yeah let's not [ __ ]
this up